and that's johnny and i also notice if
you look at that picture
like i said
on the left hand side under his eye
there's a swelling and you see a
swelling just on the left hand side of
his nose and under his left eye okay so
the johnny depp and amberhead trial has
just taken a big big swing in the
former's favor after a week of major
witness testimonies that have debunked a
lot of her claims whilst painting her
out to be the one at fault if you
watched our last video on the whole
trial then you'll know i tried to make
it a point to keep things as objective
as possible without dropping my opinion
in however after this week i think it's
going to be difficult not to just say
that amber clearly lied about a lot of
things as we have so many people that
are completely unconnected from each
other all cooperating the exact same
stories i really think this was the week
she lost a lot of credibility and though
in the build up to this it was still
pretty damning you're gonna have to just
have your fingers in your ears and your
eyes closed if you're still writing
hashtag i stand with amber heard now
before we get into the major clips i
want to firstly talk about the whole
point of a defamation lawsuit and why
depp's team are taking the best strategy
though many people are misinterpreting
this as an abuse case it isn't this is
one in which deb is arguing that his
career and reputation have been ruined
by amber heard because of the op-ed that
she put out so the point of this trial
isn't really to show that heard was the
abuser but rather it's the show she's
not a person that can be trusted however
the abuse angle is very important
because it can show she's a piece of
and therefore it kind of derails any
angle that she's the angelic figure that
she's painted herself by to be now the
major way that they break down the image
of amber this week to show that she's
untrustworthy came over the apparent 7
million donation she claimed to have
made this was apparently going to be
split down the middle between two
charities with 3.5 million going on and
the rest going to another this has
turned out to be untrue and we had a
member of the aclu come forward and
testify that amber had donated a
fraction of what she'd said she had to
make things worse a lot of the money
donated in her name wasn't actually
donated by her and it was given by
johnny depp and also elon musk sitting
here today
do you know how much
money ms heard has actually donated to
the aclu actually remitted to the aclu
um i that would be 350 000 paid directly
how much
has been paid indirectly and credited
to ms heard
um there was 100 000
um which was a check from johnny depp
there was a five thousand five hundred
thousand dollar payment from
a donor advised fund at vanguard
and then there was a 350 000 payment
that appears to be from a donor-advised
fund at fidelity
making it total 1.3 is the amount the
100 000 payment we received a check from
johnny depp's um
representatives and it was said to be
a payment in connection with
on behalf of amber heard
she confirmed that
when we initially
had contact with amber heard in 2016
she indicated her desire to pay 3.5
million dollars to the aclu so it's fair
to say that she has not
donated 3.5 million dollars as of today
to the aclu true that's true we believe
that that is a
uh donor advised fund that was set up by
elon musk and isn't he also a donor to
the aclu foundation in his own right
yes there were communications back and
forth between the aclu and miss heard
including a thank you acknowledgement
letter that mr
was sent under mr romero's name to
ms heard thanking her for the 350 000
contribution um noting that um that it
was part of her intention to make a um
3.5 million dollar contribution to the
aclu and mr romero attached to that
communication a standard aclu pledge
form we were aware
very early on
that the
her intention to contribute the 3.5
million dollars to us was half of
her seven million dollar divorce
proceedings we understood that the other
3.5 million dollars the other half was
going to
a children's hospital in los angeles now
this is pretty bad in itself but there
would be an opportunity for ambush
defense to potentially say well she
hasn't had the chance to donate it yet
or something along those lines however
what really rocks that narrative is the
fact that amber appeared on a chat show
claiming to have donated the entire
seven million already there and actually
were all kinds of accusations flying
your way when you said all this and then
there was a divorce settlement you got
seven million dollars people were saying
this is all about the money but then you
did something that uh twisted that whole
argument what did you do with that money
seven
million dollars in total was donated to
i split it between the aclu and
children's hospital of los angeles
[Music]
now one of the main things that debs
team is arguing is that amber
deliberately destroyed his career whilst
also trying to push her own they say
that she capitalized on the metoo
movement and that she also used acts
like this to prop her up as a good
person amber has been called the gold
digger quite a lot but in order to go
against this she said that she donated
the money which
that was a lie so in many ways depp's
team are using the perfect strategy in a
defamation lawsuit because they're very
much defaming amber and her reputation
so that anything she says cannot be
trusted and therefore she was the one
who's at fault for defaming johnny does
that does that make sense yeah i think
it makes sense now the next major
bombshell about this also comes from the
aclu spokesperson taran stockady who
also talked about the original op-ed
that pretty much started this entire
case this whole lawsuit revolves around
that peace which depp says ruined his
career and his reputation now you might
remember a couple of weeks ago just
before the trial started the amber put
out a post on social media this talked
about how she still had love for johnny
what was coming up in the trial and also
the op-ed amber said in the post that
she never named him and it would be a
pretty good defense position to say well
the thing wasn't about you mate it
wasn't you know like when you sub tweet
someone and then call them a dead and
then they call you out on it a lot of
the time you can get away with it by
saying well mate wasn't about you i
wasn't calling you my worst subscriber
ever your punk which you are which they
could definitely use as a defense
however the aclu did confirm that the
piece was indeed about depp
this is one of the documents you
reviewed in preparation for your
deposition
that's correct and what is it
this is an article
that um
was in us today and um
specifically
ties
amber's statements in her op-ed piece to
johnny depp
and when jessica white says
so much
for not mentioning jd
what did she mean
i speculate that she was um
saying that um
there were significant efforts made by
amber's attorneys to take out the
references
to
johnny depp in her marriage um
and
yet nonetheless
people made that connection
and in particular the
reporter for the usa today
took her
to be referring to johnny depp when she
spoke of being the victim of domestic
violence correct correct
was this was this document prepared in
the ordinary course of the aclu's
business uh contemporaneously by people
having knowledge
yes it was
maintained by the aclu in the ordinary
course of business yes um and would you
please move ahead now to exhibit 46.
um
you know
recasts everything that is said but but
ties it to johnny depp
so ms shulman is agreeing with mrs
white's characterization
that uh the usa
took mr ms heard to be referring to
her allegations of physical violence by
johnny depp correct
yes
and she says it's kind of amazing that
they just grabbed the entire op-ed and
rewrote it using johnny's name why was
it amazing i don't know why she found it
amazing
as that was consistent with your
understanding she was referring at least
in part to johnny depp correct yeah
based on my review of prior drafts of
the op-ed i knew that there were um that
she was referring to johnny depp in her
marriage physics was exhibit 46 prepared
in the ordinary course of business
by people having knowledge
contemporaneously yes
was it maintained in the ordinary course
of the aclu's business
yes
now he did also have references to her
husband so it was pretty obvious but she
may still have had some deniability
though very very little going beyond
this they also stated that they'd
actually try to remove parts of the
op-ed that were clearly about johnny
because she'd sign an nda to not discuss
their marriage herds advisors initially
revised the draft to remove
any reference
to ms heard's marriage or divorce i
recall a number of email communications
back and forth among
aclu personnel and ms heard's
attorneys
where they were
suggesting edits to the op-ed relating
to
matters covered in the mda
and then is it also true that there were
some
at the aclu
who expressed their belief
that excising those references to
her marriage
and divorce
from johnny depp
made
the op-ed less impactful correct
it is correct that is correct
but ultimately based on those voices
ms heard pushed to get
that excise material backed into the
op-ed so it could be more impactful true
that's not my understanding my
understanding is that the language that
wound up in the final op-ed piece was
very different from the original
language that robin included in the
op-ed after um having
uh
spoken with amber about her personal
experiences and how was it different
um it was it
did not refer directly to
um ms herd's relationship with um with
johnny depp
according to the testimony hood actually
wanted to put more stuff in about him
but the aclu said this was a bad idea
and they didn't want to get sued because
of the nda now this is all very much
painting out heard as being someone who
was on the attack that wanted to destroy
johnny depp's career this couple with
their marriage counsellor's statement
yeah it doesn't look good now in case
you don't know she say that heard asked
that if she struck first if it would be
better for her career and yeah that's
pretty much how it turned out so
everything seems like it was her doing
as much damage as she possibly could now
her defense have argued that depp didn't
lose his roles because of the article
that she put out this again would
further damage the defamation lawsuit as
it could show that even if it was proved
you did this it didn't have a negative
effect however this narrative was
clearly shut down by talent agent
christian carino greeno was the agent
for both heard in depth during their
marriage and he stated that depp did
indeed lose his career because of
amber's op-ed do you believe that mr
depp
is still a shroud of mystery not visible
to the public
no
and when did that change
i don't know exactly when would you say
it was cumulative over the period of
time as a result of all of the
litigation and the publicity ensuing
probably
is there any one specific litigation
that you believe most significantly
impacted
on mr depp's personal reputation no
longer being a shroud of mystery and not
visible to the public
my opinion is that amber's accusations
would have had the most dramatic impact
on
[Music]
his off-screen reputation
i'm not talking about
any
one specific
accusation
when you say amber's accusations
what do you mean by that
uh i mean the things that
she's accused johnny of doing
both
in
[Music]
that had been made public
would
amber have been filing the divorce
action
and obtaining a domestic violence
restraining order have had a dramatic
impact
on mr depp's off-screen reputation
i think the only way i can answer that
is
by saying i don't think
filing for divorce
would have any impact whatsoever
and
i'm actually not familiar with the
lawsuit to get the restraining order so
i don't know
exactly what's in there
but
if that was based on
claims of or accusations of
abuse
then that in my opinion
would have a negative impact on johnny's
off-screen reputation
are you aware of
any role or business opportunities that
mr depp lost as a result of
the op-ed by amble heard in the
washington post
are you aware of any roles or
business opportunities
that mr depp lost as a result of the
weldment tweets in may 2020 relating to
amber's out there
is there any other
role
or business opportunity
that mr depp
has lost
since
you started representing him in october
2016.
i would say
yes what
the pirates the the next pirates movie
do you remember which one that was
six seven i'm not sure what the number
is what is your understanding
of why
mr depp's
lost pirate six
my opinion
is that it was related to the
accusations
um that amber has made
what is your opinion based on
conversations with studios and
other executives both
internal and external
what do you recall jerry bruckheimer
telling you
i i don't recall the specific
conversations
but the
nature of it was that the studio was
having difficulty employing him
and did mr bruckheimer
tell you why the studio was having
difficulty employing mr duff
no not specifically but it was
understood
did you ask
i didn't need to
why did you think you didn't need to
because everyone was aware of
what was garnering the
attention of the studios and determining
whether or not he could be employed
so though all opinion based it's clear
there were rumblings in hollywood that
depp shouldn't be employed because of
the hit piece released by amber these
are very much big bombshells that were
dropped in the week but they're barely
scratching the surface as to what else
emerged firstly we had psychologist dr
shannon curry who diagnosed amber with a
personality disorder amber's defense
really tried to make curry look stupid
but in my opinion at least she
completely wiped the floor with them
whilst also showing that amber couldn't
really be trusted
dr curry you're not board certified
correct no i'm not not in clinical
psychology or in forensic psychology
correct no i'm a licensed clinical
psychologist but you're not board
certified no okay and you also have only
been practicing approximately eight
years is that correct that's not correct
how many years
i've been licensed for 10 years okay and
i've been practicing for about 15 years
okay now
you went to mr depp's home
for dinner and drinks
before you were hired as an expert in
this case correct that's not quite what
right i was interviewed at mr depp's
home by his legal team dinner was served
you in attendance with mr depp was adam
waldman correct yes
ben chu correct yes camille vasquez yes
okay and the dinner lasted approximately
three to four hours correct yes and it
includes the interviews correct
yes dinner and i believe drinks were
served okay
and this was before you were hired as an
expert correct
yes this was an interview so that they
could make an informed decision as to
whether or not to retain me
and don't you think that's a little odd
that you're getting interviewed by mr
depp
to decide whether you're going to
testify adversely against amber hurd
i was interviewed by the legal team
and mr depp was present it was his home
correct yes and he was serving dinner
and drinks he was not serving dinner
it was at his house at his behest
correct yes it was at his house okay and
you were contacted by camille vasquez
somebody you knew in the community in
february of 2020 is that correct
i knew of miss vasquez professionally we
live in the same city and i work with
many attorneys
okay
and at that time you not only knew
johnny depp you'd seen a number of his
tv and movie roles and you believed he
was a good actor correct
not correct i did not know johnny depp
i've seen several of his movies you knew
who he was yes right and you believed he
was a good actor yes okay
and then
you provided an expert designation in
this case before ever seeing amber or
having an opportunity to review any
documents or records isn't that correct
i did not provide an expert designation
that's that's an attorney thing
my opinions are contained in my report
it says you have three opinions
the first of those is that amber heard
quote
exhibits
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with co-occurring cluster b personality
disorder traits especially borderline
personality disorder did i get that
right
i'm reading that here that is not my
opinion okay well but it's a current
opinion but this was not an opinion of
mine then i didn't have any opinions at
that time it says dr curry will testify
correct that's what it says yes okay and
this is a signed pleading correct on
behalf of mr death i i'm not sure i
understand what that means
we don't understand what a signed
pleading is no okay do you understand
that mr depp's counsel prepared this and
served it on ms heard's counsel
i i'm not an attorney i don't understand
necessarily all of these procedures okay
are you aware that mr depp is on an
audio recording years earlier taunting
amber heard that she has a borderline
personality disorder i was made aware of
that in this case yes so you did
actually not necessarily taunting but i
do recall hearing that mr depp had used
that phrase so it's a coincidence
that you now think she has those
attributes after the attorneys listed it
in february 2021 before you'd looked at
anything and mr depp had made that
accusation to ms heard years earlier my
opinions aren't based on coincidences
objection i'm sorry doctor yes
compound i'll sustain the objection all
right it's a coincidence then that you
came up with symptoms of borderline
personality disorder
years later after mr depp has been
taunting this heard in an audio tape
i can't speak to whether or not there's
a coincidence what i can tell you is my
opinions are based on the results of my
evaluation and it's a coincidence that
mr depp's counsel attributed that to you
that said that to you in february 2021
before you looked at anything correct
i'm not sure okay now would you agree
that a disproportionate number of women
are tagged with a diagnosis of
borderline personality disorder
no that's not quite right
75
the way you phrase it is not quite right
tell me tell me what's right okay so
there are more women
who have been diagnosed with bipolar
disorder than men it's more prevalent in
women
now you've never been asked to testify
or serve as an expert with respect to
whether someone has a bipolar disorder
is that correct a bipolar disorder yes
that's not correct okay
i'm sorry page 207 207 line five ah
could you no okay thank you
now
when this designation was served in
february of 2021 you had not rendered an
opinion that quote ms heard exhibits
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with co-occurring classy cluster b
personality disorder traits especially
borderline personality disorder correct
i'm sorry i
i missed the first part what was that
when this designation was served that
you have in front of you as plaintiff's
exhibit 884
you had not rendered
an opinion that quote misheard exhibits
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with co-occurring cluster b personality
disorder traits especially borderline
personality disorder correct no i had
not rendered any opinions my opinions
weren't finalized until after my
evaluation right so when this came out
you had not rendered that opinion i had
not rendered that opinion okay the
second opinion that's listed in the
february 2021
is that
ms heard repeatedly and
characterologically perpetuated severe
physical and psychological intimate
partner violence ipv toward mr deb over
the course of their relationship end of
quote did i read that correctly
uh it says perpetrated but other than
that yes okay you have never been asked
to testify as to whether anyone has
behaviorally or characterologically
conducted conduct that suggests they may
be an ipv perpetrator correct
i have to ask that again because i
stumbled i can't be characterologically
that one's just a tough one for me okay
and your third opinion if we can go to
page 14
was that ms heard
exhibits patterns of behavior that
suggest her allegations of abuse against
mr deb are false end of quote do you see
that
i see that you said it's my third
opinion that is not my opinion
all right but in this pleading it says
that you will testify to that correct
yes that's what this says okay and that
was not your opinion in february 2021
was it
no as i said
i had not formed any opinions at that
time i had just been retained you have
never
arrived at the opinion that ms heard
exhibits patterns of behavior that
suggest her allegations of abuse against
mr deb are false correct
that's correct okay
and in fact you've said that has never
been my opinion correct
what i'm saying is that this the
opinions in here i these are not my
opinions my opinions are provided in my
report
so according to curry amber fits all the
definitions to be someone who lies
exaggerates and has traits of narcissism
which completely fits the narrative that
depp's team are trying to paint out it's
very very damning and beyond this we had
testimonies by three lapd officers i'm
not going to play the clip as there's
three people saying the exact same thing
but they all said that they didn't
notice any bruises unheard when they
were called out to the domestic abuse
report this further holds up the idea
that hood made at the bruises things
which backs up the milani makeup set now
malcolm connolly who acted as a security
guard for deaf and heard corroborated
much of this and stated that he'd never
seen any injuries on amber however he
did say that he'd seen them on johnny
and that these increased over time
initially they started off as scratches
which then evolved into bus lips black
eyes and slowly it got worse and worse
over time we also got this photo of
johnny and amber together on their
honeymoon in which the guy had bruises
around his left eye i've spoken to a
friend who had years of abuse in a
relationship and they said this photo
really triggered them because they
recognized the same look in their own
face when they were trying to paint out
to the world that everything was okay
however you can see a different story by
the wounds and the injuries that
johnny's carrying it's really really sad
and connolly painted out the case that
amber was the abuser and that this
escalated over time as time went on did
you have an opportunity to observe
uh how mr deputy interacted with each
other
at the beginning um oh you know
lovey-dovey everything was great the
honeymoon period was on and it was a
yeah it was good i mean it was great to
see johnny happy again amber was you
know
lovely charming
as she usually is you know
good as gold
and then things you know things started
to change amber started to change amber
started
getting a bit i would say a bit more
uh feisty
demanding you know
i could see that amber wanted to wear
the pants in this relationship that was
pretty obvious
and
what in particular made you think that
that you observed personally
um just just the way uh you know if
something wasn't quite right or
uh
amber could uh amber could get a bit
frosty at the drop of a half so as time
went on you know i could see them
i could see them change i could see i
could see amber change i could see
johnny getting quieter
uh we get into the car and nobody was
speaking
and you know just things started
changing changing amber started getting
a bit more
grumpy
did you ever observe any physical
injuries on this herd
never no
how about on mr dab
yes
yeah it started off with maybe a
a scratch once in a while or uh you know
uh
a swelling but it get got more it got
more yeah i'm not talking he was marked
every every week or every two weeks but
yeah
he he he sustained mark's here
definitely he was getting married can
you generally describe for us what you
remember about the the marks you saw on
mr depp
yes
as i was saying
any prison service you're taught to
uh
pick up log in your mind mental mental
logging in your mind
marks bruises bully patterns stuff
what i noticed right away was most of
these marks and most of these things
through my training
that's happening in the left-hand side
of his face
and it would be scratches on his neck
maybe a a fat lip in the corner
maybe a bruising on on the eye socket
um
dull impacts you know except for
obviously the scratches maybe only those
left ear sometimes it'd be two two marks
two lines two charms
one yeah you know
yeah
it was getting it was getting more
regular i might as i say not every week
but it was definitely happening yeah
can we see um
plaintiffs exhibit 162 please
and mr connolly uh are you able to see
the picture on i assume you can see it
on your screen
yeah just thank you please
yeah hi yeah
and do you uh
yeah i know that picture i took that
picture
you took pictures on your yeah i took
the picture
can you just quickly tell us uh what
what this picture is
this picture is a
miss head and johnny's
honeymoon
on the origins press on the east line
from
bangkok
to singapore
you travel through malaysia stopping the
kuala lumpur and a few other places on
the way down you just continue to
describe for us uh what we're looking at
in this picture
yeah as i said the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager
he was detailed to which you know
fixes up anything we needed
you know to excursions and
transports and stuff
then it's misheard
the guy that's the chef he looked after
this he looks he's he cooked for the
great chef by the way uh
yeah he looked after us and that's
johnny and i also notice if you look at
that picture
like i said
on the left side under his eye there's a
swelling
and you see a swelling just on the
left-hand side of his nose and under his
left eye
and what do you interpret that swelling
to be
do what do i what do i interpret it as
that's uh
either he's walked into a door
or a door's walked into him
okay
can you tell us anything and we can take
this down i think
thank you
uh mr connolly can you tell us uh well
first of all what uh
do you recall what year mr depp and and
miss heard went on their honeymoon uh in
the picture we were just looking at
um
that was
that i don't know 2013
2013
okay and were you uh well you testified
that you took the picture so you were
there i assume
absolutely yes
um
what can you tell us about that trip
generally and particularly focused on
how mr depp and ms heard were
interacting with each other
um started off good started off good uh
johnny's cabin was maybe
15 meters down the corridor from maine
there was no cabins in between there was
a like storerooms like you know blankets
and cutlery and stuff
uh so
the cabin was quite
not a big massive distance but you know
it wasn't like
chip staff is fine absolutely fine
i think there's five six days five days
maybe
two days three days into the trip uh
i can see johnny going down i can see
him coming down you know
he's just he's just not enjoying this
he's not enjoying us
but you know i can't it's not my
business to to step in than that i just
do my job but i can see he's not
enjoying this
he's not happy now this is obviously
really really bad and it shows how his
training made him pick up on these marks
over time the left-hand side of johnny's
face would be because amber is
right-handed and it really paints her
out as the abuser rather than him
there's also the door comment about him
walking into a door or a door walking
into him and though this was said as a
sort of joke it's also something that is
said about abuse victims who blame
accidents on why they're bruised rather
than the truth really sad especially as
this was their honeymoon which for most
people is one of the happiest times of
their lives
now there was also some levity in the
case this week and we had a witness
making johnny laugh throughout their
testimony guy sat in his car vaping and
he was pretty
funny anything
i don't don't remember
and you don't remember seeing anything
right but do you remember
even looking
i remember
i remember
i'm really sorry
but i remember
i gotta tell the whole story how they
got this
before the guy they went and get the
keys they come down they say somebody
try to get into my unit
there's strategies on my door say
hey like
oh um i'm really sorry but
who
will think it's gonna get into unit
because it saw some scratches on the
door like
what four inches
above the door because the dog was
scratching the door was trying to get in
and they thought about someone's trying
to break into their their unit
i said on my head i would say you're
really you think someone's trying to get
into your unit
there's scratches like four inches above
your the floor on your door that was the
dog trying to get into the unit
they were so afraid oh someone's trying
to get into my ears like oh come on
really
and i actually when they asked me to go
inside the unit just to check room by
room to make sure that no one was there
so i did that that's correct that we
don't have cameras on the videos um
sorry we don't have cameras not the
hallways
we don't have cameras on the hallway
i'm gonna
show you
uh what has been marked as romero
exhibit number one is the deposition
that you was taking of you on july
back at that time two months after the
incident
yes i don't i remember because like i
said i was
i always make eye contact with someone
i'm talking to
but i'm not looking to find something
like like oh your makeup is wrong uh
you
you haven't uh have changed your
eyebrows or your
eyelashes are not even or
i'm not looking for anything i'm just
looking at their eyes and i look i'm not
looking for anything else but if i see
something i will probably will remember
may 24
yes
yep not tuesday but in fact you don't
recall seeing amber heard on may 24th
correct
i don't remember i don't even remember
what i got for breakfast
okay
well let's pull up
exhibit number one
so yeah all in all once you look at this
stuff from all these different people it
becomes crystal clear what's happened
and i think amber is gonna have a hard
time even equaling it let alone
surpassing it with her own evidence i
think she's gonna have to have johnny on
tape hitting her in 4k in front of an
audience to even fire back at this as
it's so one-sided at the moment amber
was also debunked in her claims by
having ptsd from the relationship by a
clinical test which disproved pretty
much everything she said it's not
looking good and with it now being
reported that she only has 10 minutes of
screen time in aquaman too you've got to
be thinking that warner brothers are
going to try and redo this with a
different actress the internet has
really been up in arms too and the
petition to replace her in the film now
has passed 2 million signatures that's 2
million people that don't want to see
her work which shows how bad this whole
trial has been for her people actively
hate her and it's not just to the point
of well i don't like vin diesel because
he's not that good of an actor it's like
no i actively hate her and i want to see
her entire life ruined also i don't know
why i brought up bin diesel there first
name that came to mind and before you
start i actually like the guy give us
faster than the furious triple x i'm
here for it so yeah moving on i think
the evidence is so stacked against er
that it's gonna be hard to fight against
it but we still have a long way to go
let me know your thoughts below on the
case and if you enjoyed this recap then
please hit the thumbs up button and make
sure you subscribe i am gonna try and
cover this case once a week as a lot of
you requested ongoing coverage on the
last video so yeah make sure you stay
locked i'll leave that video on the
screen right now if you haven't seen it
and we've got a packed week with
moonlight and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness coming up hope to
see you soon thanks for sitting through
the video take care peace